週刊金融日記
2026年9月22日 第七百四十九号
エーアイで科学研究はどれぐらい加速していくか考えました
シルバーウィーク明けはしゅうきんぺい主席とトランプ大統領が会談へ
鹿児島で美味しい鶏刺しを食べながら生食規制について考えました
エーアイ革命が続く中で個人ができること
他
web版
こんにちは。
ふじさわかずきです。
熊本の地震で、九州新幹線が分断されてしまっていたのですが、18日にとうとう復旧し
ました。
そして、復興支援もあり、僕も18日の早朝に香港を出発して、お昼には福岡空港
に到着して、その足で博多駅から九州新幹線に乗り込み、鹿児島までやってきました。
九州新幹線、全線で運行再開　熊本 - 新水俣間が復旧、52日ぶり―ホームに長蛇の列
「感謝」
ホテルの朝ごはんで食べる明太子が美味いですね。
あと、日本はやっぱり白いご飯が美
味いわ、と思いましたわ。
ぜんぜん高級ホテルじゃないんですけど。
さっそく、翌日の早朝に、錦江湾へ釣りに行きました。
サバとかアジとかめちゃ釣れま
した。
あと、タイも釣れました。
一軒家を借りているので、自分たちで調理して食べます
台風25号の影響で、シルバーウィーク中の東京は豪雨だったみたいですね。
鹿児島は晴
れておりました。
観測史上１位の記録的大雨　台風ピークすぎても災害警戒
なんと皇居まで冠水したようですね。
気候変動で豪雨の頻度と強度が上がっているので
すが、それに下水インフラが追いついていないみたいですね。
最近、また半導体株が上がってきましたが、そのきっかけのひとつとなったオラクルの
決算について、分析レポートをアップしました。
Xサブスク（月３USD）は、アップルやグーグルにピンハネされるスマホのXアプリか
らではなく、宇宙かいはつを応援するためにも、天才イーロン・マスクさんのXのWebをブラ
ウザで開いていただいて、そこから直接ポチっていただけると助かります。
品川駅周辺の美味しいレストランをとうとうまとめました！
（Xサブスク）
オラクル FY2027 Q1｜エーアイじゅようは本物だった
こんしゅうも読者から興味深い投稿がいくつもあります。
見どころは以下のとおりです。
-所長のエーアイによる企業分析でのプロンプトや事前データの工夫についてご教示ください
-私もエーアイで多忙になりましたが儲かっておらず、これが続くなら早晩エーアイ企業が投資した資
金を回収できなくなるのでは
-仕事も夫婦生活もじょうずくいっているのに恋愛がじょうずくいきません
それではこんしゅうもよろしくお願いします。
１．エーアイで科学研究はどれぐらい加速していくか考えました
ほんの１年ぐらい前まで、たぶん2025年の夏ぐらいまで、Webリサーチやコーディング
などいくつかの分野以外、エーアイは割とポンコツでした。
難しいことはいろいろ微妙で、門外
漢が70、80点ぐらいのものを作るのには使えるけれど、優秀な専門家が自分の分野でやる
仕事なら、ぜんぶ自分でやったほうが速いし、そもそも難しいことはできないし、ハル
シネーションも多く、使い道に相当な限界があったわけです。
デモとか見たり、たたき台
作ったりすると、すごく使えそうで、実際に使ってみるとなんか使えない、みたいな状況
が続いていました。
こうした状況が、明らかに変わったのは、ことしの６月にFableが出たあたりからです
ね。
ついさいきんの出来事です。
僕も主要企業の決算分析レポートをXのサブスクで提供する
ようになりましたし、さまざまな分野でリサーチ能力が一気に上がり、知的ワークなら、
もはや使わないという選択肢はほぼない、というところまで来てしまいました。
IT分野で
は、それよりだいぶ前からすでにそうなっていましたが、知的ワーク全般でこうなってき
たわけです。
アンソロピックが「Claude Fable 5」をリリース。
“高性能すぎて限定だったMythos”の一
般公開版
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十八号 エーアイにより我々の知的生産性は爆上げしてめちゃくちゃ多忙になり
暮らしに余裕もなくなりましたが収入も増えません』
こんしゅうはChatGPTとClaudeの性能が加速度的に上がっていることを受けて、人類の科学研
究の発展速度がどれぐらい上がりつつあるのか、いろいろ書いておこうかと思います。
つい最近、オープンエーアイが流体力学のナビエ・ストークス方程式で有限時間で速度が発散す
る特異点が起きることを証明したと発表しました。
また、オープンエーアイはミレニアム懸賞問題
全てに取り組んでいると発表しており、人間の数学者が何十年も解けなかった問題を次々
と解決していきそうだ、と報道されています。
ナビエ?ストークスのミレニアム懸賞問題について
[EN]●How an AI math breakthrough ignited a controversy[/EN]
先日も、UCLAの数学サークルに参加する２人の高校生が、ポスドク研究者の指導を受
けながらエーアイを使って、フィールズ賞受賞者June Huhが解き残していた、ローレンツ多項
式の難問を解いたと話題になりました。
[EN]●2 High School Students & A Postdoc Have Used AI To Apparently Solve A Math Problem[/EN]
[EN]That Had Stumped A Fields Medalist[/EN]
[EN]●Bathija, A., Rohatgi, P., & Soskin, D. (2026). Bounded ratios for Lorentzian polynomials ([/EN]
[EN]arXiv:2609.05341).[/EN]
もちろん、エーアイがこれらの研究を勝手にやっているわけではなく、人間の数学者と協業し
ています。
少なくとも、人間の数学者が解くべき問題を選別して、エーアイを動かしているわけ
です。
オープンエーアイもアンソロピックも、だいたい年間１億円?２億円ぐらいの報酬で著名な数学者
を雇っているようで、未発表の最先端モデルと膨大な計算リソースを与えて、こういうマ
ーケティング的に効果がありそうな数学の難問にアタックさせているわけです。
ナビエ・
ストークス方程式の問題については、まさにアンソロピックがこの分野の著名な数学者と共同研
究をしていて、かなり手がかりをつかんだことを発表しそうだという噂を聞きつけて、
オープンエーアイが一気に計算リソースを投入して先に解決したみたいなことになって、いろいろ
揉めていますが……。
いずれにしても、人類の科学研究において、もうエーアイが、いぜんのようにそれっぽいもの
を高速で作るという域を完全に脱してしまい、一線を越えてきたのは誰の目にも明らか
ではないでしょうか。
それで、じつは最近、僕もエーアイと協業しながらアカデミアの学術論文を書いています。
自分で言うのもなんですが、僕はめちゃくちゃ論文生産性が高かったんですよ。
学部の
ころから物理のトップジャーナルに載せて、大学院でもたくさん書いて、ファーストオー
サーで全部で10本ぐらい、すべてトップジャーナルに掲載されました。
そこそこ優秀な博
士課程の学生の３倍ぐらいの論文を３分の１ぐらいの時間で「生産」した計算になります
ね。
まあ、いろいろ運が良かったし、環境に恵まれてたんでしょうけど。
しかし、金融機関に就職した後は、当たり前ですが、そういう活動はきっぱりとやめ
て、会社の仕事に専念しました。
就職した後も物理の論文の査読依頼はちょくちょく回っ
てきたんですが、当然のようにぜんぶ断っていたら、リストから外されたみたいで、１、
２年ぐらいしたら全く来なくなりました。
まあ、アカデミアはそれなりに楽しめたし、科学者の仕事としては小さな達成感は得
たし、外資系証券会社でそれなりに金も稼いだし、作家としてもいろいろ本を書きまし
た。
就職してからは物理なんかぜんぜんやっていなくて、分野としては、ずっと社会科学
なわけです。
経済、金融、そして、人間行動の科学です。
こうしたことをずっとやってき
て、これまでなんどか書きましたが、物理はとくいでそれに一点集中したら海外の大学院にお
金をもらいながら行ける！
というのでやっていたんで、特に何の未練もなく、圧倒的に人
間社会を読み解く社会科学の方が僕は面白いと思っているし、人生をかけてずっとやって
いきたいものです。
たまに物理から着想を得たモデルとか発表できたらなぁ、とかは思い
ますが。
だから、社会科学やファイナンスなどの分野で、ちゃんとした学術論文をいつか
書いてみたい、という思いは心のどこかにずっとありました。
自分で言うのもなんですが、計算資源を投入したらスケーリング則でほぼ確実に性能が
上がるエーアイといっしょで、時間と労力のリソースを投入したら、僕の実力的には社会科学の
論文ぐらい書けるわけです。
面白いネタ、面白い切り口はいろいろありますし、なんとい
っても、金融では長年の実務経験があるし、社会科学の女王である恋愛工学を実務研究者
としてこれまでやってきました。
『週刊金融日記 第五百二十一号 地方出身の平凡な大学生だった私が海外大PhDコースにフルサポ
ート奨学金をもらって留学できた夢をつかむ力』
しかし、実際に査読を受けるちゃんとした論文を書くとなると、なかなか大変なわけで
す。
この仮説をこういうデータで検証したら良い論文になる、というアイディアがあった
としても、まず先行研究を調べないといけません。
文献リサーチだけで１、２ヶ月。
その
分野で常識になっている数理モデルや検証手法をひととおり勉強するのにさらに１、２ヶ
月。
仮説を確かめるためのデータ収集に１、２ヶ月。
分析コードの実装に１、２ヶ月…
…、と１本の論文を書くのに、やっぱりフルタイムでがんばって半年はかかるわけです
よ。
いやいや、他分野の学術論文を半年で書けたら、かなりすごいんですが、かなりすご
いことやっても半年ぐらいはコミットしないと無理なんですわ。
さすがに、アカデミアの論文って、ブログ記事とかその辺の雑誌のコラムとか、あと、
証券会社のアナリストとかエコノミストとかが書くレポートとかと比べて、めちゃくちゃ
大変ですからね。
証券会社のストラテジストとか、なんか適当にあのチャートとこのチャ
ート持ってきて、両軸グラフでいい加減にスケール合わせて、あたかも因果関係がある風
な適当なこと言ってればいいですが、学術論文ではそうはいきません。
膨大な先行研究を
調べて、自分の研究の立ち位置がどこで、どんな新規性があるのかとか、しっかり書かな
いといけません。
僕はブログも雑誌のコラムも証券会社のレポートもアカデミアもぜんぶ
土地勘があるんですが、ざっくり言うと、ブログとか雑誌の１、２ページの長いコラム
は、プロなら１日仕事で、証券会社が書く何らかのテーマの深堀りレポートでもせいぜい
２、３週間ぐらいなもんです。
しかし、学術論文を１本なら、やっぱり半年から１年ぐら
いの仕事という感じです。
そして、雑誌のコラムも証券会社のレポートも、ちゃんと報酬
がもらえますが、学術論文はそれ自体は１円にもなりません。
アカデミアのポジションを得るのに必死なポスドク研究者や、出世競争をしている大学
教授でもなければ、１円にもならない論文のために本業を半年も休んでフルコミットする
なんてできません。
そもそも能力的にできる人がアカデミア以外ではほとんどいない上
に、そういう稀有な人がいても、時間・労力的にとても許されないんですわ。
ところがです。
このハードルがエーアイでめちゃくちゃ下がりました。
上の学術論文を書くた
めの各ステップをそれぞれ１、２ヶ月と見積もりましたが、１、２日とは言わないまで
も、最先端のエーアイを使うと数日で終わっちゃうんですよね。
エーアイは、こういう学術研究の作業
が特にとくいなんです。
具体的に見ていきましょう。
まずは、文献リサーチです。
昔は、大学でしか使えない有料データベースでキーワード
で引っ掛けて、とりあえずそれっぽい論文を何本か見つけてきて読んで、その参考文献リ
ストをたどって、また読んで、と芋づる式にやっていったり、となかなか大変でした。
ま
あ、その間に、いろいろ知識がついていくので、無駄ではないんですがね。
他分野だと、
そもそもどのジャーナルが一流で、誰が大御所で、どの論文が必読なのか、という土地勘
がまったくないので、これがめちゃくちゃ時間がかかるんですわ。
さらに、在野の研究者
だと、高い論文データベースにアクセスできないんで、無料のグーグル Scholarとか、無料
で読めるプレプリントサーバーとかを手がかりに探していかないといけないですね。
いまは、エーアイに自分の仮説を入れて、関連論文をリストアップしてくれと頼むと、何十本
も洗い出してきて、誰が何を主張しているのか一気に出てきます。
自分のアイデアがそれ
ら関連論文の描き出す地図の中でどんなところに位置しているのかが、綺麗に整理されて
いきます。
一発で出なくても、いろんな角度からエーアイをぶっ叩き続けていけば、２、３日で
相当な精度で文献リサーチが終わってしまうんですよね。
もちろん有料データベースを使
えないのはエーアイも同じなんで、そういう問題はありますが、エーアイが違法に（笑）学習していた
り、いまはプレプリントサーバーにだいたい元の論文があったりするんで、かなりいい仕
事ができます。
次に、その分野の数理モデルの勉強です。
これは、めちゃくちゃ優秀で、何時間質問攻
めにしても嫌な顔ひとつしない大学教授レベルの家庭教師が、24時間ついているようなも
のですし、なんせ、これPythonでじっそうして、と言えば、標準的なものなら、ほぼ間違いの
ないじっそうが30分ぐらいでできちゃうんですよ。
まあ、適切な指示ができれば、という前
提ですが。
昔なら、大学院レベルの教科書を２、３冊買ってきて、必死で勉強していくしかなかっ
たわけです。
論文を１本書くのに必要なのは、教科書のごく一部なんですが、そこまで
たどり着くのが大変です。
しかも、まさに必要な箇所が、せっかく読んだ厚い教科書に載
ってなかったりもしますしね。
いまは「このデータをこういう目的で分析するには、どの
モデルを使えば良いか？
」と聞けば、ピンポイントにエーアイが教えてくれます。
さらに、こい
つが、前述のように、24時間ついている大学教授レベルの家庭教師なわけですね。
僕は金
融機関でクオンツの仕事やってたし、物理の研究者もやっていた人間なんで、社会科学の
道具立てのほとんどはちゃんと説明してもらえば分かるものばかりです。
知らないのは、
その分野の方言と作法なんですが、エーアイが家庭教師として懇切丁寧に教えてくれちゃいま
このように、ある分野の専門家が、隣の分野に入っていくときなど、いまのエーアイはめちゃ
くちゃ力を発揮するな、と思うわけです。
３つ目は、データ収集です。
実証研究をやったことがある人ならわかると思いますが、
こういう社会科学分野だと研究時間の大半が、じつはデータの入手と前処理に消えてい
きます。
どこにどんなデータがあるのか。
欠損値はどうするのか。
ソースによって違うフ
ォーマットをどう合わせるか。
こういう論文には数行しか書かれないようなことですが、
やらないと何も始まらない泥臭い作業が山ほどあるわけです。
これも、エーアイに聞けば、公開されているデータソースを教えてくれて、データを取ってく
るコードから、前しょりのコードまで、ぜんぶ出てきます。
ちなみに、素人はエーアイにデータそ
のものを作らせようとしますが、これは絶対にダメで、エーアイにデータを取得するコード、そ
れらを整形するコードを作ってもらい、自分でデータを作らないといけません。
金融の世
界には、高額なデータベースがいろいろあり、これは在野の人間にとってはいまでも壁
なんですが、無料で使える公開データだけでも、昔とは比べものにならないぐらい、いろ
いろなことができるようになりました。
４つ目が、分析コードの実装です。
ここは、IT分野でとっくに起きていたことが、そ
のまま研究にも当てはまります。
エーアイはプログラミングがめちゃくちゃじょうずいです。
ちなみ
に、素人は、エーアイにいきなり研究の大きなプログラムを書かせようとするんですが、機能分
離できるところは徹底的に分離しないといけません。
さまざまなデータソースからデータ
を収集して、それを分析に使えるように整形して、分析して、分析した結果をいろいろ可
視化して間違いがないかチェックすると同時に、論文などに載せるテーブルやチャートを
作るところ、と機能を分けることができます。
この場合、データ取得＋整形、取得した
データの可視化、分析そのもの、分析したデータの可視化、と最低でもこれぐらいプログ
ラムを分離しないといけません。
この辺は、エーアイいぜんのソフトウェア開発といっしょで、エーアイ
使う場合、正直、何やるにしても実務経験豊富なシニアの方がじょうずいです。
こういう社会科学の実証系の学術論文が、証券会社のレポートと決定的に違うのは、適
切な統計モデルで検定などをひととおりやって論じないといけないことです。
こういうレ
ベルで統計学ができる人は、高学歴の中でもほんの一握りしかいませんから、そもそもほ
とんどの人にこうした学術論文を書く最低限のスキルさえないわけです。
証券会社のなん
ちゃってクオンツアナリストとか、なんか適当にあのチャートとこのチャート持ってき
て、両軸グラフでいい加減にスケール合わせて、あたかも因果関係がある風な適当なこと
言ってればいいですからね。
さいごが、論文の執筆です。
英語の推敲、LaTeXでの組版、参考文献のフォーマット合
わせ、投稿先のジャーナルごとの細かい規定への対応。
こうした、時間を食う作業は、か
なりの部分をエーアイに投げられます。
日本人研究者がずっと背負ってきた英語のハンデは、論
文を書くという点では、ほぼ消滅したと言っていいです。
エーアイいぜんにも、機械翻訳の性能が
だいぶ上がって、日本人は楽になったんですが、英語でいちばん困る冠詞（aとthe）など
名詞の問題（単数形なのか複数形なのかなど）は文脈に依存するので、自動翻訳じゃダ
メなんですよ。
そこが文脈まで把握できるエーアイにより、ノンネイティブでもほぼ完璧な英文
が書けるようになりました。
そして、とても便利なのが、エーアイに意地悪な査読者の役をやらせることです。
「あなたは
この分野のトップジャーナルの査読者です。
この論文をリジェクトする理由を挙げてくだ
さい」などと言うと、なかなか痛いところを突いてきますね。
こうして、投稿する前に、
穴をあらかた塞いでおけるわけです。
こういうのは、大学のラボに所属していて、いろい
ろ議論できる人が身近にいないと難しかったんですが、それもエーアイでできるようになりまし
このように学術論文の生産性は、特に理論研究や、ネットで収集できる公開データだけ
でできる実証研究に関して言うと、劇的に上がりました。
以上は、大学などの研究機関に
所属していない、僕みたいな在野の実務側の人から見た視点なのですが、容易に想像でき
るのは、研究者が自分の専門とはちょっと違う分野に進出しようという時のハードルを、
エーアイは劇的に下げただろうな、ということです。
僕が気付いていない広範な領域で、エーアイは
すでにアカデミアの研究支援を推し進めているように思います。
実際に、数字にも表れています。
ある学術誌では、ChatGPTの登場以降、投稿数が42％
も増えたそうです。
数学でも、arXivへの投稿が、15年間ほぼ一直線だったトレンドか
ら、ことしの第２四半期には２割ほど上に飛び出しています。
エーアイの国際会議のAAAIにいたっ
ては、2025年の約１万5000本から、2026年は３万本超へと、投稿数が倍増しました。
ざ
っくり言って、多くの分野で論文の投稿数がいぜんより３、４割は増えている感じで、エーアイの
性能向上を考えると、こんごはもっと増えそうです。
[EN]●More Versus Better: Artificial Intelligence, Incentives, and the Emerging Crisis in Peer[/EN]
Review
[EN]●Mathematical Articles On ArXiv Have Risen 20% Over Trend In 2026[/EN]
[EN]●AI-Assisted Peer Review at Scale: The AAAI-26 AI Review Pilot[/EN]
さて、ここでひとつの疑問が湧いてきます。
これって、エーアイによって、ゴミクズみたいなコンテンツがインターネット上に大量生産さ
れているのと同じことが、学術論文の世界でも起きているだけなのではないか？
というこ
とです。
いまやネットを検索すると、エーアイが書いた、中身がスカスカのSEO記事が山ほど出てきま
す。
Xを開けば、エーアイボットが投資詐欺へ誘導するリプを付けまくっています。
YouTubeに
も、エーアイ音声がエーアイ台本を読み上げるだけの動画があふれてきました。
論文の数が増えたとい
っても、これと同じで、単にゴミが増えただけなのではないか、と。
実際に、そういう指摘はあります。
arXivは、でっち上げの参考文献など、明らかにエーアイ
が生成した内容を含む論文を投稿した研究者を、１年間出入り禁止にすると発表しまし
た。
エーアイゴミ論文は、たしかにそれなりに存在するわけですが、これは査読とは関係ない、
とりあえず著者が研究成果を載せておくプレプリントサーバーの話です。
流石に、本当のゴミ論文は査読を通らないのですが、それでも、エーアイで量産された質の低
い論文が増えていく、という問題はあるでしょう。
[EN]●A key science publishing platform is cracking down on AI slop[/EN]
エーアイで論文を書くハードルが下がっても、ゴミ論文が増えるだけということも考えられま
しかし、僕の意見では、これらは全体から見れば大したボリュームではなく、いま起き
ているのは、本質的な科学の進展速度の上昇だと考えています。
理由は２つあります。
ひとつ目は、単純に、実際に本当に生産性が上がっているのを、肌身で感じるからで
す。
これまで書いてきたように、文献リサーチも、モデルの勉強も、データ収集も、コー
ドの実装も、ぜんぶ圧倒的に速くなりました。
そして、速くなったからといって、質が
落ちているわけではないです。
むしろ、エーアイがじっそうしてくれるので、さまざまな数理モデル
を昔の10倍は試せますし、意地悪なエーアイ査読者になんどもダメ出しされるんで、質は上がって
います。
少なくとも、それなりの研究者がエーアイを適切に使えば、上げられます。
冒頭で紹介
した数学の成果も、ゴミどころか、人間の数学者が何十年も解けなかった問題が解けたと
いう話なわけです。
ふたつ目は、インセンティブの問題です。
これが決定的に重要です。
ネットにエーアイゴミコンテンツがあふれるのは、それが金になるからです。
SEO記事は広
告収入になるし、FacebookやInstagram、Xなんかにエーアイがばら撒く投資詐欺広告も、詐欺
なんだからボロい儲けでしょう。
エーアイゴミを撒き散らす金銭的なインセンティブがあるか
ら、エーアイゴミが量産されるのです。
簡単な話です。
ところが、前述のように、論文というのは、書いても１円も得しません。
原稿料はゼ
ロです。
それどころか、ジャーナルによっては、投稿料を取ったり、アクセプトされた後
に掲載料を払わないといけません。
では、なぜアカデミアの研究者は、死に物狂いで論文
を書くのでしょうか。
それは、直接的には金を稼ぐことが要求されないアカデミアという
世界では、論文こそが通貨だからです。
論文を稼いでポジションを得て、論文を稼いで昇
進して、論文を稼いでテニュア（終身在職権）を取る。
これが稼げないとゲームオーバ
ーで、失業する世界なんですね。
逆に言えば、このアカデミアのゲームに参加していない人にとっては、論文は何の価値
もない通貨です。
ビットコインと違って、円にもドルにも換金できません。
だから、門外
漢がエーアイを使ってゴミ論文を作るインセンティブが、そもそもないわけです。
とはいえ、局所的にはゴミ論文を生産するインセンティブがあります。
それは誰かというと、たとえば、研究が嫌いになったか、あるいは能力不足で、もうア
カデミアには見切りをつけていて、違う分野の民間企業に就職するなりして、とにかく早
く学位だけ取って切りをつけたい博士課程の学生です。
こういう学生が、エーアイを使ってゴミ
論文を生産して、学位取得に必要な本数をそろえる、というのは大いにありえます。
とい
うか、たぶんいま、世界中でやっていると思います。
しかし、こういう人は、エーアイゴミ論文をめでたく生産して、学位を取得したあとは、もう
アカデミアの研究はしないわけです。
二度と論文を書きません。
だから、その害悪は限定
的でしょう。
誰にも引用されないゴミ論文が、ジャーナルの片隅に何本か残るだけで
す。
そんなものは、エーアイが登場するずっと前から、人間の手で大量に生産されていました。
さらに、エーアイが登場する前は、こういう人たちはデータを捏造したり、もっと悪いことして
いたかもしれず、その点では、むしろほとんどエーアイで書いた論文の方が質が高いです（笑
ということで、肌感覚では、2026年の現段階で、エーアイによって、科学技術の進展のスピー
ドは、控えめに見ても２、３割は上がっていると思います。
２、３割というと大したことないように聞こえるかもしれませんが、これはとんでもな
いことです。
こういう漸進的にしか変化のないもので、一気に何割も生産性が上がるっ
て、もう紛れもない本物の革命ですよ。
2027年は、エーアイはもっと性能が上がるので、このスピードはもっと上がりそうです。
いま
は理論や、公開データだけでできる研究が先行して加速していますが、実験が必要な分野
でも、仮説を立てるところや、実験データを解析するところは、すでに同じように加速し
ているはずです。
エーアイによって、たとえばバイオ研究が加速して、がんなどの病気の治療法に大きな進展が
ある、なんて話は、もう夢物語ではないのかもしれません。
追記：
配信直前に、オープンエーアイの内部モデルが、100件以上の数学の未解決問題を解いたと発表し
ました。
しかし、社会に対する影響が大きいため、どう成果を評価し、公開していくかな
ど議論するため、独立した数学者の諮問委員会を設置したとのことです。
エーアイのこういう形式科学での性能の向上は加速していて、まったく減速する気配がありま
せんね。
スケーリング則がまったく崩れません。
[EN]●OpenAI forms math advisory group as its AI resolves more than 100 open problems（[/EN]
TechCrunch）
エーアイが推進するサイエンスは、また、人々の予想をはるかに超えるスピードで進んでいき
そうです。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十六号 スケーリング則でエーアイの性能が順調に上がっても性能が上がりすぎ
るからこそ国家に規制されてダメになる論について』
２．こんしゅうのマーケット
2026年9月11日-2026年9月18日の週間パフォーマンス
[EN]TOPIX:       4091.14, +1.6% (1w), +19.4% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Nikkei225:  65018.95, +1.6% (1w), +29.2% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]S&P500:      7650.50, -0.1% (1w), +11.8% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]USD/JPY:      156.13, +1.7% (1w),  -0.2% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]EUR/JPY:      179.20, +0.6% (1w),  -2.5% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Oil(WTI Fut): 100.30, +0.2% (1w), +74.7% (YTD)[/EN]
オラクルがエーアイじゅようを確認し半導体株堅調、日米そろって利上げ、シルバーウィーク明けは
しゅうきんぺい主席とトランプ大統領が会談へ（金融日記 Weekly 2026/9/11-2026/9/18）
せんしゅう（9月11日−18日）のかぶしきしじょうは、日米の金融引き締めと原油100ドルという逆風
のなか、エーアイ関連株には買い戻しが入った。
TOPIXと日経平均はともに週間で1.6％上昇
したいっぽう、S&P500はほぼ横ばいだった。
米国ではAMD（+8.5％）、Micron（+4.2％）、
Alphabet（+3.3％）、メタ（+2.7％）、エヌビディア（+1.8％）などが上昇した。
WTI原油
先物は100ドル台で高止まりしている。
米中央軍によれば、ホルムズ海峡の原油輸送は直
近２週間で６カ月ぶりの高水準まで回復したものの、週末にはフーシ派がサウジの首都リ
ヤドをミサイルとドローンで攻撃したと主張するなど、中東情勢は依然として不安定であ
エーアイ相場については、先々週発表されたオラクルの決算が強烈な需要確認となり、その
余波が続いている。
Q1売上高は前年同期比30％増、クラウド・インフラは121％増、受
注残は6640億ドル。
この四半期だけで850メガワット、30万基超のジーピーユーを顧客へ引き渡したに
もかかわらず、稼働率は97.9％だった。
さらに契約更新を迎えたジーピーユーは約20％高い価格
で再契約され、その過半は導入から４年以上経った旧世代ジーピーユーだった。
「エーアイデータセンタ
ーを作りすぎてジーピーユーが余る」「ジーピーユーはすぐ陳腐化する」という弱気論とは正反対の実績
である。
もちろんオラクル自身には、年間900-950億ドルものせつびとうし、フリーキャッシュフロー
赤字、1250億ドルきぼの有利子負債という資金面の問題がある。
しかし、エーアイサプライチェ
ーンを見る上で重要なのは、エーアイじゅようの強さが、またひとつ実績で裏付けられたことであ
る。
オラクルが巨額のせつびとうしを続ければ、その支出はエヌビディアやAMDのジーピーユー、MicronやSK
hynix、Samsung、キオクシアのメモリ、さらにサーバー、ネットワーク、電源・冷却設
備の売上になる。
市場もそこを素直に読み、せんしゅうはAMDやMicronを中心にエーアイ関連株が上昇
した。
オラクル FY2027 Q1｜エーアイじゅようは本物だった（Xサブスク）
マクロでは、エフアールビーと日銀が同じ週に利上げへ踏み切った。
エフアールビーは政策金利を0.25％引き
上げて3.75〜4.00％とし、３年ぶりの利上げを実施した。
ウォーシュ議長はインフレが依
然として高すぎるとの認識を示し、FOMC参加者18人のうち16人が年内に少なくとももう
１回の利上げを見込んでいる。
日銀も政策金利を1.00％から1.25％へ引き上げたが、決定
は７対２で、しじょうが期待したほど明確な追加利上げの道筋は示されなかったため、発表後
はむしろ円安が進んだ。
週間でもドル円は153円台から156円台へ円安となった。
そして、こんしゅう、日本はシルバーウィークである。
21日の敬老の日から23日の秋分の日ま
で東京しじょうは3営業日連続で休場し、週末を合わせて5連休となる。
その日本しじょうが休ん
でいる23日にしゅうきんぺい国家主席が米国入りし、翌24日にホワイトハウスでトランプ大統領と
の首脳会談に臨む。
トランプ大統領はアンドルーズ統合基地まで自ら出迎える予定で、
Jensen Huangら米企業トップも晩餐会に出席する見通しである。
首脳会談では、11月に期限を迎える関税休戦の延長、中国のレアアース輸出、米国の半
導体・先端技術規制、エーアイの安全保障上のルールが重要な論点となる。
中国側は技術規制の
緩和を求め、米国側はレアアースなど重要鉱物の供給改善を求めているほか、農産物や
Boeing機の追加購入、台湾、イラン、フェンタニル原料も議題となる見通しだ。
首脳会談
に先立ち、20日にはベッセント財務長官と何立峰副首相がニューヨークでエーアイ、貿易、レア
アースを巡る協議に入る。
米中が関税やレアアースで部分的な休戦にたどり着いても、エーアイと半導体を巡る国家間競
争そのものが終わるわけではない。
短期的には、半導体輸出規制やレアアースについてど
こまで具体的な合意が出るかが、エヌビディアをはじめエーアイ関連株の大きな材料になる。
シルバ
ーウィーク明けの日本しじょうは、日米の利上げを消化すると同時に、米中首脳会談の結果を
一気に織り込むことになりそうだ。
米長期金利、一時５パーセント台　２年11カ月ぶり、インフレ・財政懸念
米長期金利５パーセント・日本は３パーセント　市場、インフレ制御に不安　原油高・財政拡張続く
エフアールビーが３年ぶり利上げ決定、年内あと１回予想　議長「インフレ高すぎる」
日銀1.25パーセントへの利上げ決定、物価上振れリスク抑制　２人が反対票
フーシ派、サウジ首都を攻撃　７月以降初、石油施設で火災も
ホルムズ原油輸送６カ月ぶり高水準と米軍発表?フーシはサウジ首都攻撃
習氏到着、異例の出迎えへ　首脳会談へ23日米国入り トランプ氏
エーアイや貿易「休戦」が議題　24日に米中首脳会談
Xサブスク（3USD/月）で、主要企業の決算分析や、エーアイバブルの現在位置について筆者
とエーアイの対談記事が読めます。
購読希望の方は、アップルにピンハネされるiPhoneアプリか
らではなく、スマホやPCのブラウザからXのサイトを開き、そこで直接サブスクリプショ
ンを登録して、ついでに、イーロン・マスク氏の宇宙開発も同時に応援してください。
9月21日(月)
休場：日本（敬老の日）
9月22日(火)
米2年国債入札
休場：日本（国民の休日）
9月23日(水)
米9月サービス部門購買担当者景気指数（PMI）
米9月製造業購買担当者景気指数（PMI）
米5年国債入札
しゅうきんぺい国家主席米国到着
休場：日本（秋分の日）
9月24日(木)
米4-6月期経常収支
米8月新築住宅販売件数
米7年国債入札
米中首脳会談（ホワイトハウス）
独9月Ifo企業景況感指数
9月25日(金)
米8月耐久財受注
米9月ミシガン大学しょうひ者態度指数
9月26日(土)
9月27日(日)
３．ブログではいえないお店
-鹿児島で美味しい鶏刺しを食べながら生食規制について考えました
また、日本に用事があり、鹿児島に来ております。
さっそく鶏刺しを食べました。
ギラン・バレー症候群で深刻な後遺症が残った人の話がXでバズっていた時に南九州民
が鶏刺しの画像をアップして、僕も鶏刺しぐらい食べようなどと言ったら、さらに炎上し
ていました。
この鶏刺しはめちゃくちゃ美味かったです。
僕の理解では、鶏刺しは日本では鹿児島県と宮崎県だけが、県独自の厳しい衛生基準を
設けており、スーパーでも売っていますし、もちろん居酒屋なんか行くと鶏刺しは置いて
ありますし、今回紹介するお店みたいに専門店もたくさんありますね。
ということで、鹿
児島県と宮崎県はめちゃくちゃ当たり前のように食べています。
要は鶏というのは腸内にカンピロバクター菌という食中毒を引き起こす菌がいるんです
が、いくら新鮮でも、調理の過程で腸を触った包丁とかが他の部位に触れたりしてまずい
わけです。
鹿児島県と宮崎県では、そうした汚染を防ぐための厳しい独自基準（表面の加
熱殺菌や専用器具の使用など）を設けて鶏の生食を提供しているわけです。
鶏の刺身「鳥刺し」の謎　どうして鳥を“生”で食べられるの？
鹿児島のソウルフ
ード調べてみた
それで、僕はてっきり鹿児島と宮崎以外では、鶏肉の生食は法律で禁止されているのか
と思っていたら、むしろ、鹿児島と宮崎は独自の厳しい衛生基準で提供していますが、そ
れ以外の日本では、鶏肉の生食提供そのものを一律禁止する法的規制は何もない、という
ことです！
つまり、東京の衛生管理が悲惨な居酒屋とかで、鶏刺しを提供しても、それ
自体は何ら罰則がない、と。
明確に法律で禁止されているのは、言わずと知れた牛のレバ刺しなどと、豚肉（肉も内
臓も）ぐらいということみたいです。
知らんかった！
しかし、前述のように、カンピロバクターによる食中毒は、ごくまれにギラン・バレー
症候群を引き起こします。
これは体の免疫が菌を攻撃しようとして暴走し、自分の末梢神
経まで攻撃してしまう自己免疫疾患です。
菌の表面にある分子と、神経を覆う髄鞘や軸索
の分子が似ているため、抗体が敵と自分を取り違えるのが仕組みだとされています。
典型
的な経過は、下痢などの感染から数日?数週間後に、足先のしびれや力が入らない感じか
ら始まり、両足・両手へと広がり、重い例では歩行できなくなり、呼吸筋まで麻痺して人
工呼吸器が必要になることもあります。
死亡率はおおよそ１％前後とされ、多くの人は数
週間で回復に向かいますが、重症だった人ほど後遺症が残ることもあります。
そして、たまたまこういう重症患者や死亡例がほんの数例起きて、前述のようにバズる
と、レバ刺しと同様に、政府は規制に乗り出すわけですね。
生食用の鶏肉 衛生基準などのガイドライン初めて策定へ 厚労省
韓国ではレバ刺しもユッケもガンガンと食べられます。
２年前ですけど、食べてきまし
たわ。
『週刊金融日記 第六百四十二号 ソウルでユッケと活きたタコを食べてきた』
いやいや、鶏の生食の前に、もっと規制するものがあると思うんですよね。
それ規制す
るなら、そもそも煙草とか酒とか全面禁止にしておけよ、と。
自動車の運転は一般人には
許可するなよ、と。
百歩譲って規制するなら、ずっと厳しい基準で、伝統的にみんな食
べている鹿児島県や宮崎県も禁止にするんか、と。
この先、どうなるか分かりません
が、困ったものですね。
さて、冒頭の鶏刺しの写真ですが、じつはいま霧島に来ております。
まあ、この原稿を
書いている時点では、初日なんで、よく分からんのですが、山があって豊かな自然で、国
宝の社殿を持つ霧島神宮があって、温泉があって、とこの辺の南九州の軽井沢的なところ
ですかね。
それで、Airbnbに泊まっているのですが、夕飯はどこも予約してなくて、直前に、食べ
ログなどで点数が良いレストランに電話したら、連休だから当たり前なんですが、どこも
満席で、空いていたのがここです。
みやま本舗です。
じつはここは、鹿児島中央駅にもあるし、鹿児島の市街地に数軒あるチェーン店で、同
行した人は鹿児島にかなり馴染みがある人で、霧島まで来てみやま本舗かよ、と不満そ
うでしたが、僕的には、鶏刺しとかめちゃくちゃ美味しく、満足でしたな。
他に焼き鶏もあって、これも美味しいですわ。
あと、写真載せてないんですが、黒豚焼
きもめちゃ美味かったです。
僕は、むしろ、鹿児島の良い地鶏料理のチェーン店（といっても、この原稿書きながら
調べたら鹿児島県内に数軒あるだけみたいですが）を、霧島で見つけたわ、という感じで
すわ。
みやま本舗 霧島店
鹿児島県霧島市霧島田口1611-10
0995-57-0201
ということで、霧島については、また、らいしゅう以降に書こうと思います。
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.1
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.2
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.3
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.4
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.5
金融日記 レストランリスト No.6 飲食不毛の地と言われる品川駅周辺の美味しいお店
しんせん・南油服装卸売しじょうの歩き方 2026年
４．ふじさわかずきの身もフタもない人生相談
-所長のエーアイによる企業分析でのプロンプトや事前データの工夫についてご教示ください
いつも魅力的なメルマガを楽しみにしています。
所長は投資や企業分析で生成エーアイをかなり使い込まれており、単に質問を投げるのではな
く、情報の入れ方や分析・すいろんのさせ方まで相当工夫されているのではないかと想像して
います。
もし差し支えなければ、以下の２点について、普段どのような工夫をされているか教え
ていただけないでしょうか。
【インプットデータ】
企業分析や投資分析をさせる際、決算資料やアナリストレポート、業界資料など、参照さ
せる情報源やデータの与え方をどの程度設計されていますか。
【分析・推論】
生成エーアイにありきたりな要約や定性的な分析をさせず、仮説や示唆の質を高めるために、プ
ロンプト、個人設定、分析フレーム、役割設定などで工夫されていることはありますか。
特に、所長のように投資家・執筆家として使う場合、いっぱん的な生成エーアイの使い方とはかなり
違うのではないかと思っており、そのあたりをぜひ伺ってみたいです。
-ふじさわかずきの回答
Fableもジーピーティーも、決算分析はかなり力を入れたエーアイを仕上げてきているので、さいきんでは、プ
ロンプトを工夫しなくても、だいたいいいものが出てくると思いますね。
しかし、EPSのアナリストコンセンサスとかは、集計会社が有料で提供していて、自分の
証券会社のアプリでは見れるけど、エーアイからは見れないので、エーアイはそれらの二次報道を使っ
たり、無料情報で適当にやりますね。
はいぱーすけーらーみたいな超大企業だと、二次報道だけで十分な情報があるんですが、
そういう無料で得られない系の情報は、このEPSデータを使ってくれとか、事前に与える
方がいいでしょうね。
まあ、あと、想定読者に合わせて、どこを重点的に書いてほしいかなど指示することです
超有名企業だと、そんなこと冗長になるんですが、たとえば、日本の読者に中国企業を紹
介する場合は、ちゃんと創業からの物語とかも入れてほしいじゃないですか。
あとは、出てきたレポートを他のエーアイにチェックさせたりとか、まあ、いろいろあります
ということで、まともな決算レポートを出すには、200USDぐらいはChatGPTとClaudeに
課金しないといけないし、割とトークン消費の激しい仕事なんで、エーアイ、半導体、中国株な
んかの投資に興味がある方なら、僕の３USD/月のXサブスクは、自分で作るよりはるか
に安いし、こうしたエーアイレポート作るのも、なんだかんだと大変なんで、すぐ元が取れると
思います。
だいぶ記事が溜まってきました。
メルマガと違い、Xサブスクは課金すると、過去の記
事もぜんぶ読める仕様です。
ひと手間かけて、iPhoneやAndroidのアプリ経由ではな
く、ブラウザ開いて、XのWebから直接ポチっていただけると幸いです。
-私もエーアイで多忙になりましたが儲かっておらず、これが続くなら早晩エーアイ企業が投資した資
金を回収できなくなるのでは
藤沢先生、いつも楽しくメルマガを拝読しております。
第七百四十八号のコラム、まさに自分の状況そのもので深く頷いてしまいました。
私もエーアイに重課金して知的生産性は爆上がりし、毎日寝る暇もないほど忙しくなりました
が、先生の仰る通りアウトプットの基準が上がっただけで、ちっとも儲かっておりませ
そこで質問なのですが、僕たち現場の人間がこれだけエーアイを使い倒しても売上や利益が増え
ないのだとしたら、いまビッグテック各社が莫大な資金を注ぎ込んでいるエーアイへの投資は、
結局どこかで回収できなくなってバブルが弾けてしまうのではないでしょうか？
先生のご見解をお聞かせいただけますと幸いです。
-ふじさわかずきの回答
いやいや、その心配は全くないんですよ。
たしかに、エーアイにより知的ワークの生産性は上がったんですが、僕も含めて、みんな忙しく
なったものの売上はほとんど増えていませんよね。
だったら、早晩、エーアイ企業は莫大な投資を回収できなくなると思うかもしれませんが、むし
ろ、逆に、もっと回収できるわけです。
個人や企業の競争も、国家間の競争と相似形で、僕たちはもう、決して降りられない競争
に入っているわけですよ。
たしかに、エーアイを使ったからって、僕たちは売上を増やせたり、余暇が増えて人間的な暮ら
しができるようになったりしないようです。
むしろ、真逆ですね。
しかし、エーアイを使わなかったらどうなるかというと、この競争に一瞬にして負けて、今より
はるかに惨めな暮らしになるんですよ。
心理学者のダニエル・カーネマンとエイモス・トベルスキーが提唱したプロスペクト理
論によると、人は利益を得ることよりも、損をすることを極端に嫌い、不確実な状況で非
合理な判断をしてしまいます。
こうした行動経済学の研究で、ダニエル・カーネマンは2002年にノーベル経済学賞を受賞
しました。
つまり、エーアイを使ったら儲かるぞ！
より、エーアイを使わなかったらあなたのキャリア、あるいは
あなたの会社は瞬く間に転落していくぞ、と脅される方が、はるかに課金を誘引します。
僕は、はいぱーすけーらーもオープンエーアイもアンソロピックも、すでに儲かっていて、その収益
性については全く心配していませんが、なんせはいぱーすけーらーは、別にある本業の方
が世界で圧倒的なトップに君臨する、独占企業たちなので、なおさら心配いりません。
だって、マイクロソフトがOfficeの値段を２倍にするって言ったら、どこの企業も払わざるをえ
ないじゃないですか。
グーグルが、YouTuberの報酬減らして、ピンハネをもっとするって言っても、もう動画プ
ラットフォームとして独占的な地位になってるから、クリエイターもそこでやらざるをえ
ませんね。
Instagramだって同じです。
なんだかんだと、企業はInstagramに広告を出さざるを得ないんですよ。
Instagramなんか、あれだけ炎上しても、炎上どころかド犯罪の詐欺広告とかバンバン掲
[EN]載していますが、いまでもLVMH（Vuitton、Dior、Fendi、Loewe、Celine、Tiffany な[/EN]
[EN]ど）も、Kering（Gucci、Saint Laurent、Bottega Veneta、Balenciaga など）、Chane[/EN]
l、Richemont（Cartier など）も広告出し続けているし、エルメスだってちゃんと
Instagramに広告出しているんですよ。
Xだって、他にこんなプラットフォームありませんわ。
だから、知的ワークをやっている人たちからは直接課金で唸るような金をエーアイで巻き上げま
すが、エーアイを利用しない人たちからも、ちゃんとエーアイの研究開発やエーアイデータセンター建設のた
めの金を搾り取っていくわけです。
というわけで、どう考えても、エーアイに金が吸い込まれ続ける未来しかないわけで、だからこ
そ僕は、これほどツルハシ半導体株、特にメモリ株を買っておいたほうがいい、と繰り返
しメルマガに書き続けているわけですよ。
エーアイに重課金して武装した人間同士の大競争バトルロワイヤルに参加して生き残っていく
か、あるいは、エーアイツルハシ株に投資しておくかしか、僕たちのようなホワイトカラー民に
は生き残る道はないわけですね。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十五号 なぜエーアイと半導体をめぐる天井なき果てしなき軍拡競争は決して避
けられない運命なのか』
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十六号 スケーリング則でエーアイの性能が順調に上がっても性能が上がりすぎ
るからこそ国家に規制されてダメになる論について』
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十八号 エーアイにより我々の知的生産性は爆上げしてめちゃくちゃ多忙になり
暮らしに余裕もなくなりましたが収入も増えません』
-仕事も夫婦生活もじょうずくいっているのに恋愛がじょうずくいきません
いつもメルマガを拝読しております。
恋愛について、自分なりに考えたり試行錯誤したりしているのですが、最近どうしても理
解できないことがあり、ご相談させてください。
現在、仕事や金銭面については順調です。
仕事では結果が出ていて、収入面についても自分としては非常にうまくいっています。
また、結婚しており、夫婦関係も悪くありません。
ところが、なぜか女性関係だけが最近極端にうまくいきません。
もともと恋愛が特別得意だったわけではありませんが、さいきんは、一人の女性と会うところ
まで行っても、一度会っただけで断られたり、場合によっては実際に会う前に電話をし
ただけで急に相手の温度が下がったりすることが非常に増えました。
「自分の何が悪いのか」を考えているのですが、原因がどうしても掴めません。
そこで、直近で特に象徴的だったＳ子という女性とのケースについて、ご意見を伺いたい
です。
Ｓ子とは、マッチングアプリで知り合い、ここ２週間ほどLINEでやり取りしていました。
まだお互いに顔写真を交換していませんでした。
それにもかかわらず、LINE上ではかなり感触が良く、相手から電話したいと言ってきた
り、かなりノリよく会話が続いていました。
その時点では、少なくとも相手から見て私は「話していて楽しい」「感じがいい」という
評価を得ていたと思います。
実際、電話は今回が２回目だったのですが、１回目の電話では私はほとんど聞き役に回
り、相手の話を「うんうん」と聞くことを意識しました。
その後Ｓ子から、
「◯◯くん、すごく優しい声をしていて楽しかった」
というような非常に好意的な感想をもらいました。
そのため、２回目の電話もかなり良い流れになると思っていました。
ところが、２回目の電話の翌日、Ｓ子から突然、
「色々考えてたんだけど、△日に会う約束してたけど、今回はなしにさせてほしい」
と言われ、会う予定をキャンセルされました。
そして、それ以降ほとんど連絡がなくなりました。
つまり、２週間ほどかけて非常に高かったと思われる評価が、たった30分程度の2回目の
電話を境に、ほぼ一気にひっくり返ったように感じています。
ここが今回、一番理解できないところです。
２回目の電話で私が話した内容を振り返ると、少し恋愛観について深い話をしました。
私は幼馴染の女性と結婚してから、仕事が非常に忙しく、長い間ほとんど恋愛をしてきま
せんでした。
朝５時まで仕事をしていたこともあり、恋愛に時間を使うよゆうがありませんでした。
そのため今は、
「過去にできなかった恋愛を取り戻すつもりで恋愛をしている」
という話をしました。
そして、
「なんにんもの女性と遊びたいというより、一人、本当にだいじな人を見つけられればいいと
思っている」
ということも話しました。
また、
「セックスだけをするのであれば、極端な話、風俗に行けばいいと思う。
でも自分は心
がないと全然ダメだと思う」
という趣旨のことも話しました。
Ｓ子はこの話に対して、その場では特に否定的な反応はせず、
「仕事が忙しくて恋愛する時間がなかった」
という部分についても、
「私もそう」
と共感してくれていました。
その後は普通の雑談をして、電話自体は30分程度で終わっています。
少なくとも電話の最後まで明らかに険悪だったわけではありません。
だからこそ、翌日の急なキャンセルが非常に不可解でした。
もちろん、自分でも仮説はあります。
私は「ゴールデンサークル理論」のWHY→HOW→WHATの考え方を恋愛にも応用し、
「自分が何を考えている人間なのか」「なぜ恋愛をしているのか」という部分を相手に伝
えることで、単なる条件やスペックではなく、自分自身に興味を持ってもらいたいと考
えていました。
今回も、それによって会う前の好感度をさらに上げようと思って、意図的にこうした恋愛
観を話しました。
しかし、今振り返ると、
「一人だいじな人を見つけたい」
「心がないと意味がない」
などの話が、Ｓ子からすると想像していたよりも重く、
「この人は思ったより恋愛に必死なのではないか」
「自分が求めている恋愛とは違うのではないか」
と感じさせてしまった可能性も考えています。
また、私はその電話の際にお酒を飲んでいました。
Ｓ子にもそれは分かっており、翌日にもそのことについて触れられました。
そのため、酔っていたことによる距離感や話し方も悪影響だった可能性があります。
ただ、それにしても、「少し重い話をした」程度で、翌日に会う約束を取り消し、その後
ほぼ連絡を絶つほどまで温度が下がるものなのか？
という疑問があります。
もし私が同じ話を女性からされたなら、むしろ「ちゃんと恋愛をしたい人なんだな」と感
じて好印象になります。
しかし、相手が女性の場合は全く違う受け取り方になることもあると思います。
このあたりを恋愛工学的にどう評価されるのか知りたいです。
さらに、今回のＳ子の件だけではなく、さいきんの私の恋愛全体に同じようなことが起きてい
ます。
一度会っただけで断られる。
あるいは、さいきんでは実際に会う前に電話をしただけで、急に相手の温度が下がる。
そして、自分としては「いぜんより恋愛について勉強し、相手の話を聞くことも意識し、プ
ロフィールやコミュニケーションも改善している」つもりなのに、結果だけを見るとむし
ろいぜんより悪くなっています。
いっぽうで、仕事については非常にうまくいっています。
お金についても順調で、仕事上の自己評価はかなり高いです。
夫婦関係も悪くありません。
つまり、仕事・金銭・家庭は比較的うまくいっているのに、恋愛市場だけが異常なほど結
果が悪い、という状態です。
このこと自体に何か関係があるのでしょうか。
仕事では成功しているからこそ、恋愛でも「自分ならこうすれば相手に好印象を与えら
れるだろう」と考えすぎてしまい、恋愛を仕事と同じように最適化しようとしているので
はないか、とも考えています。
逆に、仕事がうまくいっていることによって、自分では気づかないうちに女性とのコミ
ュニケーションに何らかの癖や傲慢さ、必死さ、コントロールしようとする姿勢が出てい
る可能性もあるのではないかと思っています。
そこで、藤沢さんに以下の点についてお伺いしたいです。
・Ｓ子はなぜ、たった一度の30分程度の電話を境に、そこまで急激に温度を下げたのでし
ょうか？
私が話した恋愛観、酒、距離感、自己開示の仕方などの中で、恋愛工学的に見て特にまず
かった可能性があるものは何でしょうか。
・仕事や収入が非常にうまくいっているいっぽうで、恋愛だけがうまくいっていないことに
は、何か構造的な関係があるのでしょうか？
単純に別々の問題として考えるべきでしょうか？
・こんご、自分は具体的にどういう方向で恋愛を改善していけばいいでしょうか？
特に、
「会う前の好感度を上げたい」
という気持ちが強いのですが、そのために自己開示や恋愛観を伝えようとすること自体が
逆効果なのであれば、どのようなコミュニケーションに切り替えるべきでしょうか。
もし今回のようなケースを分析するのに必要なメルマガや過去のバックナンバーがあれ
ば、ぜひ教えていただきたいです。
今回のＳ子の件は、単に一人の女性に断られたというだけではなく、
「自分が良かれと思って考えて行動したことが、なぜ女性から見ると逆効果になるのか」
を理解するためのケースだと思っています。
仕事ではPDCAを回すことでかなり結果を出せているのですが、恋愛だけは何度やっても
原因が分からず、最近かなり行き詰まっています。
恋愛できる時間も永遠にあるわけではないと思っているので、できるだけ早く自分の問題
点を特定して、こんごの恋愛に活かしたいと思っています。
かなり長くなってしまいましたが、もしお時間があれば、Ｓ子のケースと、さいきんの私の恋
愛全体について、恋愛工学の観点からご意見をいただけると大変ありがたいです。
よろしくお願いいたします。
-ふじさわかずきの回答
いや、恋愛において、ストナンでもクラブナンパでも出会い系アプリでも、その場では意
気投合して、次のアポを入れたのに、アポがなくなるみたいなのは日常茶飯事です。
株価の日々の上げ下げみたいなもんで、特に深く考えても意味はありませんので、数を打
って、統計的なアプローチをするしかないですね。
Good Luck!
追記：
恋愛工学の基本を学びたかったら、とりあえず古典となったバックナンバーを読みましょ
恋愛工学 重要バックナンバー
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。